there's people that love your songs Just
because they sound good yes sir but
there's also people that love your songs
because they come from you yes sir I
understand that I guess the thing that
I'm concerned is you can still tell if
it's an AI song right right now but the
way that it's moving like I feel like
the attention span is getting so short
now with like short form content and
stuff like that and it's super instant
gratification so it's like as a fan of
someone right even as a fan in a couple
of years I don't see why they're like
hey I want post Malone to make a song
about this thing that specifically
happened to me with the specific
person's name in it with this stuff and
this is super relatable to me and I
that's what I want so then you can just
type in the prompt all this and
it'll just out a song and it'll be
the most personalized experience for you
that's weird isn't that weird